[Musique]
il
bonjour à tous la grande interview
enregistrée dans des conditions encore
particulière pour cause de distanciation
sociale la grande italie avec cette
semaine boris cyrulnik bonjour à vous
merci de nous parler de votre lieu de
vie ou de vos lieux de travail mais
votre lieu de vie c'est votre travail
actuellement
mais voilà vous êtes chez moi dans mon
bureau ravis de vous accueillir dans mon
bureau avec une immense bibliothèque
derrière parce que vous devez vivre dans
les livres les chiffres rouler les dés
moyen âge voilà je passe un temps fou à
fouiller à retrouver les livres alors
vous êtes neuropsychiatre
c'est votre métier c'est votre formation
vous dis avait passé l'essentiel de
votre vie le grand public vous connaît
parce que vous avez écrit beaucoup de
livres qui sont très accessibles et ça
c'est assez rare chez un expert sur un
terreau chercheurs de chercher à être
accessible du grand public je pense à la
la psychothérapie de de dieu sur dit
jacobs c'était il ya deux trois ans je
pense aussi à la nuit j'écrirai dès
soleil je pense que c'est peut-être le
dernier livre que vous avez publié
bref je vais pas résumer votre parcours
je dirais quand même que votre démarche
si j'ai bien compris invite les
individus à prendre conscience de ce
qu'ils sont et et d'assumer ce qu'ils
sont que ce qu'ils font que ce qui leur
arrive
est-ce que et c'est la première question
vous considérer aujourd'hui que les
français assument bien où j'allais dire
parfaitement bien ce qui se passe
l'horizon jusqu'à maintenant bien
résisté il va falloir maintenant
déclenché un processus de résilience est
pas la même chose
la résistance s'est plutôt bien passé la
plèvre les français d'une manière
générale ont presque tous été adepte du
confinement ils ont respecté les
consignes ça a effectivement limiter la
propagation du virus
mais après une situation de catastrophe
physiques psychologiques et sociaux
économiques
il va falloir maintenant se remettent à
construire et l'art je pense que il va y
avoir des débats
chaleureux chaleureux et parfois
difficile sur le plan social sur le plan
politique on va en parler dans un
instant vous parlez de résilience c'est
le concept sur lequel vous avez beaucoup
travaillé et c'est un concept que vous
avez un peu populariser comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est la capacité de résister c'est la
capacité de rebondir
comment est ce que vous le résume le
définissent yevou il n'y a pas de
définition plus bébêtes est plus logique
que la résilience c'est après un
traumatisme qu'est ce qu'on fait combien
on reste traumatisée ce qui arrive dans
ce cas là ya pas de résilience ou bien
on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et là on parle de
résilience c'est à dire que la
résistance on est dans l'affrontement
que c'est ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à
maintenant on a affronté plutôt bien et
maintenant il va falloir se remettre à
reconstruire une autre manière de vivre
ensemble et là ça va dépendre des
rencontres des débats du talent des
philosophes des scientifiques et des
journalistes alors qu'elle était la paix
la question que je voulais vous poser
de quoi dépend une bonne résilience est
ce qu'il ya des peuples plus résilient
que d'autres et ça dépend de leurs
gouvernants ça dépend de leur éducation
satorp en dollar du système dans lequel
ils vivent
ça dépend de quoi vous avez employé le
mot clé système c'est à dire qu'on peut
pas établir de causalité linéaire on
peut pas dire si le gouvernement est bon
on va reprendre un bon développement si
les individus sont bons va reprendre un
bon développement peut pas des raisonner
comme ça on peut raisonner en termes peu
évolutif c'est à dire avant le
traumatisme
certains parmi nous avait déjà acquis au
cours de leur développement des
créateurs de protection une famille
stable
une aptitude au langage un métier qui
leur permettaient d'acheter de louer ou
d'acheter un grand logement de supporter
le confinement
ceux là vont fournir la population où il
y aura beaucoup de gens qui vont
reprendre un bon processus de résilience
qui définit la résilience
al'inverse certains parmi nous avant le
confinement avait déjà acquis les
facteurs de vulnérabilité famille
difficile maltraitance maladie difficile
accès au langage pas de bons métiers
petit salaire donc petit logement donc
confinement difficile et cela vont vivre
le confinement comme un traumatisme
supplémentaire et ceux là auront du mal
à reprendre un processus de
développement résilient si on les aide
car si on laisse tout seul cela vont
rester traumatisés si on les aide un bon
nombre d'entre eux pourront reprendre un
bon développement
mais là il y aura du travail alors c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
je me disais à l'instant il semblerait
que les français aient bien supporté et
bien assumer ce qui se passait ils ont
été à un comportement responsable c'est
ce que vous disiez
or les français objectivement donné le
sentiment d'être très vulnérable être
très fragile
on sort d'une période agitée les gilets
jaunes sera quand même traumatisée et ça
a bousculé le tissu social on a une
défiance pour ne pas dire une très
mauvaise confiante dans l'exécutif dans
la classe politique
tout ça sur des facteurs négatifs pour
assurer une avait un rebond exactement
tout ce que vous me dire c'est
l'acquisition de facteurs de
vulnérabilité qui fait que je suis un
peu inquiet pour les débats nécessaires
qui doivent avoir lieu maintenant jeu
depuis quelques décennies on ne sait
plus débattre c'est à dire qu'il ya plus
de lieux de réflexion philosophique
écologique sociologie on sait plus
débattre on choisit son camp donc on
choisit son clan c'est à dire qu on ne
raisonne qu'en ce groupe que entre ceux
qui tiennent les mêmes raisonnements et
ça c'est catastrophique parce que c'est
ce qu'on insère qui était en place en
avant c'est un facteur de
communautarisme c'est à dire c'était
déjà un facteur de vulnérabilité qui
s'était mis en place depuis plusieurs
décennies où les gens se regrouper par
croyance
ans religieuse croyances laïcs croyants
ce profane il se regrouper par croyance
entre les était bien mais quand un
groupe est clos quand c'est un clan à ce
moment là le clan généralement part en
guerre contre le clan d'à côté et ça
c'est un facteur de mauvaises résilience
mais ces clans ces communautés il y
avait aussi les idéologies on était
classé par idéologie
c'était relativement simple un cd
facteurs qui structure la société
française aussi et qui lui permettait de
maths de maintenir un certain équilibre
alors je dire autres danses et les
facteurs qui stricte structure qu'un
individu dort son groupe mais qui
fragilise la société française puisque
pour que la société française soit
résiliente il faudrait que ont ce qu'on
accepte de se mettre d'accord sur
certains points de reconstruction
or ces derniers temps moi ce qui me
navre est c'est de voir que les
scientifiques les politiciens les
journalistes les philosophes aimé
discuter mais les politiciens
dès que se faisait des déclarations de n
dès la deuxième phrase c'est à dire
qu'il est impossible de trouver une
solution
quand on fonctionne comme ça il n'y a
que des rapports de force et on voit que
beaucoup de régime s'effondra ne sont
pas beaucoup société ne reprennent pas
développement résilient quand elle
fonctionne comme ça l'envoi des
effondrements alors que au contraire
certaines sociétés qui garde une
cohérence reprennent un bon
développement résilient si vous me
donnez 2000 juste un petit exemple pour
illustrer ce que je viens de dire mon
ami michel tousignant qui est professeur
de sociologie à montréal travaille avec
les indiens du guatemala un dictateur au
river chasse tous les indiens pour
prendre leur territoire ce que font tous
les colonialistes donc les indiens sont
chassés par l'armée
et le hasard les divisent en deux
groupes un groupe qui reste près de la
frontière où ils s'organisent garde la
langue garde les rituels et se
structurant femme et un autre groupe qui
va plus loin dans des camps anomique
sauf structure sans tradition perdre le
langage puis le dictateur tombe parce
que c'est ce que les dictateurs ont dû
mieux à faire assez de chuter
il finit par tomber les indiens
reviennent chez eux au guatemala et
quels sont ceux qui reprennent à des
bons développements résilient ceux qui
étaient restés groupés entre eux avec la
même langue avec les mêmes rituels alors
que les hauts fonds issus d'une
population presque tout le monde presque
tous les individus étaient traumatisés
alors si je comprends bien lorsque vous
dit vous avez dit dans les jours là qui
viennent précédé ce que nous traversions
c'est pas une crise c'est une
catastrophe
mais c'est exactement le langage
qu'utilisent les chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui et les économistes mais ils
font allusion à la catastrophe
économique et sociale
j'imagine que vous vous faisiez allusion
à autre chose c'est-à-dire à une
catastrophe type dictature ou dip
reprise en main par pas reparu
d'autocratie quelconque annoncé sa non
catastrophe c'est un mot général comme
évolution que c'est un bon général qui
concerne les plantes qui vont faire de
la biologie ce qui concerne les hommes
qui concerne les sociétés donc
catastrophe ça veut dire à côté
cata strophe line il ya un tournant et
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
donc c'est la définition de la
résilience donc je pense que les chefs
d'entreprises emploient le bon mot en
parlant de catastrophe au centre soit on
l'emploie aussi en biologie il ya des
cinq extinctions jusqu'à maintenant
depuis sur la planète on le sait puisque
on voit que quand il ya vu lui un
réchauffement
l'eau monte et on voit que à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
il y a des coquillages et des poissons
qui sont imprégnés dans la pierre donc
il y avait l'eau de mer à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
et on voit que quand l'on en reparle
autres phone et une autre flore et
apparaît donc c'était la situation de
catastrophe caractérise la biologie
comme la société mais et le festival dit
qu il ya deux choses que l'on vit
actuellement
on a vécu la peur du virus et on
continue de vivre avec cette peur du
virus
tant qu'on n'aura pas ni traitement ni
vaccin vraisemblablement encore qu' il y
ait des maladies comme le sida sur
lesquels on a trouvé des traitements
très tard et on n'a toujours pas trouvé
de deux vaccins
bref
la crainte du virus mais il ya aussi les
conséquences des réponses que nous avons
apportées à ces virus
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
est lié directement au confinement c'est
à dire à la mise en coma artificiel de
l'économie alors ça c'est un énorme
problème pour moi c'est un problème
éthique qui n'est jamais arrivé dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est à dire que c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines ont provoqué en
ruines
la moitié de la planète est ce qu on a
bien fait avant il ya même pour la
dernière épidémie jamais on a fait ça
jamais on laisser mourir les gens disent
eh ben voilà c'est pas chance il ya une
épidémie typhus et ben voilà il ya la
guerre est un deuxième guerre mondiale
quand même fait 50 millions de morts et
donc au diable voilà seul destin de
chaque fois qu'il y avait une épidémie
de typhus ou quand je dis quand j'étais
enfant il y avait la polio et audi ben
voilà il ya le virus de la polio de 30
ans un enfant meurt ou un enfant et
mutilés pour toute sa vie et en accepter
là c'était la condition humaine jamais
mon pensé qu'il fallait arrêter la
problème les sociétés pour lutter contre
le virus ont cherché dans les
laboratoires et maintenant c'est la
première fois humaine que les états ont
pris cette décision invraisemblable qui
finalement est un problème éthique
c'est fait d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vaud où c'était une
décision totalement normal est
totalement logique ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribue à la vie à la mort et
à la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des suicides
il va y avoir des ruines il va y avoir
des enfants qui pourront pas reprendre
un bon développement parce que leurs
parents seront ruinés il va y avoir des
dettes
je sais pas alors là je suis pas
économiste mais j'imagine que la dette
de la france va être énorme
j'imagine que l'aviation vache ou une
valve a débauché et changer de manière
de fonctionner donc il va y avoir des
catastrophes lui-même individuel avec
cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat moral
un débat éthique il va ya voir même un
débat politique sur ce tissu sur ce
thème là dans la mesure où vous avez un
certain nombre de personnalités
notamment aux états unis ou en
angleterre qui ont prôné le non
confinement pour pouvoir préserver les
actifs de production
c'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on faisait
jusqu'à maintenant quand il y avait une
épidémie
le corium les épidémies de peste il ya
eu beaucoup d'épidémie de peste qui sont
partis marseille parce que marseille est
un grand port est qui et qui amenait des
vivres et surtout la route de la soie
passé par marseille donc les gens pour
gagner de l'argent
vous voyez à qui je banques pour gagner
de l'argent ne respectez pas la
quarantaine
donc les épidémies de peste des marais
est entré 148 1 européen sur deux est
mort en deux et ont trouvé voilà c'est
là pas de chance c'est la condition
humaine
il ya eu énormément d'épidémie comme ça
quand les mongols ont souffert au xiiie
siècle ont souffert de sécheresse
ils sont descendus vers le sud de la
chine
il ya eu des guerres il ya eu la grande
muraille de chine
il ya eu des guerres entre les mongols
des chinois un chinois sur deux est mort
c'est à dire que c'était les
catastrophes qu'on n'imagine pas
aujourd'hui il ya eu la catastrophe de
l' esclavage en afrique où le point
continent entier a été ravagé par
l'esclavagisme des arabes et des
chrétiens et on disait ben voilà c'est
la condition humaine c'est pas de chance
et là c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de même que pour sauver des
vies pour lutter contre la mort on
n'accepte plus la mort est en ruine des
pays
comment vous jugez la façon dont dans
l'exécutif a géré cette crise et
notamment sur l'aspect très particulier
du rôle
on a donné aux experts aux médecins à
vos confrères dans ce conseil
scientifique dont on a eu le sentiment à
un moment qu'ils avaient à total pouvoir
sur le déroule
événement et oui et ça aussi c'est une
nouveauté c'est que le gouvernement a
été fait par le scientifique et que les
politiques la plupart du temps la
plupart de leur décision était prise
après un rapport scientifique on peut
considérer que c'est un progrès puisque
les scientifiques père m'ont permis à la
société de s'améliorer c'est la science
c'est l'hygiène c'est la science la
médecine et max qui ont permis aux
hommes et aux femmes
aujourd'hui d'avoir une espérance de vie
de presque 100 ans pour les flammes
un peu moins pour les hommes c'est la
science qui a permis que un bébé sur
deux ne meurt pas dans la première année
ce qui a été la règle
la progrès c'est un progrès magnifique
duo scientifique donc nos décideurs
politiques ont décidé que c'est les
scientifiques y aurait le pouvoir de
décision
alors ces voix là ils ont fait le choix
éthique de donner leurs pleurs pouvoir
de le déléguer aux scientifiques
imaginons que dalle ya des pays qui
l'ont pas fait 30 ne voulais pas je ne
voulais pas le faire au début c'est des
virologues proche de 32 de niveau
international qui en réussit à le
convaincre
et c'est extra a cédé il aura cédé
points
il y a quand même énormément aux états
unis actuellement sitruck n'avait pas
cédé le pouvoir offrir aux log américain
il y aurait encore plus de morts donc
les mêmes trains pas accepter d'écouter
les scientifiques pour économiser des
vies humaines
il a ruiné l'écho d'une grande partie de
l'économie américaine mais il a fait un
choix
donc si je sais pas que là il va y avoir
un débat où les philosophes le sentiment
de la mort vont primer sur la manière de
vivre en société
je n'ai pas la réponse
si j'ai une réponse personnelle mais je
sais pas quels rapports flou le groupe
français va conclure vous dites vous
dites il va falloir tirer les leçons de
cette catastrophe
il va falloir sans doute vivre autrement
vous pensez vraiment qu'on va vivre
autrement
j'ai passé
avait lu le texte de michel houellebecq
il dit c'est peut-être l'obsolescence
des relations sociales de jadis on en
aura plus jamais comme on en a eues
auparavant
alors c'est ce qui se passe après une
catastrophe ou bien on remet en place le
conditions d'avant c'est à dire ce que
font beaucoup de simples de
d'industriels donc ce que déjà beaucoup
de politiciens proposées on se remet au
travail et en accélère les cadences pour
rattraper le temps perdu
donc on va refaire les conditions qui
ont fabriqué les virus depuis le
néolithique depuis dix mille ans on sait
comment se fabriquent ces catastrophes
virale et bastille vers le stockage des
aliments et le transport des virus et
des bacilles stockage consommation
transport avion entre on sait ce qu'il
faut faire si on remue pardonnez moi ça
m djoko ça a un lien direct avec la
mondialisation avec le développement du
transport aérien avec l'excédent de
consommation eh bien vous alors ben
voilà mais c'est certain c'est toujours
en depuis le dix mille ans c'est
toujours ce que vous venez de dire qui a
déclenché des épidémies mondiales 2 et
russe
alors si on remet en place les mêmes
conditions et bien dans deux ans il y
aura un nouveau virus
ou alors on cherche organise à vivre
autrement et dans ce cas là il faudra
trouver des moyens de produire on pourra
pas vivre sans économies mais est ce que
on pourra continuer à aller chercher le
de l'autre côté de la planète des choses
qu'on peut fabriquer nous mêmes
est-ce qu'on va continuer à acheter des
biftecks argentin un bifteck argentins
avant d'arriver chez un boucher français
ces deux fois le tour de la planète en
avion d'envoyer le dax carbone donc
est-ce que ça est ce qu'on peut faire
on achète des légumes en amérique du sud
alors que nous on en produit on fait
faire nos tissus en chine alors que nous
on sait le faire on avait des signatures
on avait même des magna n'aurait pour
faire la soie comme les chinois
donc voilà donc il va y avoir un débat
où les économistes vous auront leur mot
à dire
mais peut-être qu'il faudra changer la
manière de produire et changer la
manière de partir en vacances
et peut-être aussi changer la manière de
travailler on dit que les français se
sont habitués par exemple à ce que nous
sommes en train de faire actuellement
c'est à dire un télétravail est ce que
vous a convaincu de sa est ce que vous
n'avez pas avoir des français qui dans
six mois ou dans un an je dire écoutez
le télétravail c'est bien mais on a
quand même envie d'aller sortir d'aller
se frotter vous avez excéder 2 face aux
excellentes un jour c'est que le rapport
personnel c'était c'était quasiment
l'énergie de l'intelligence il faut il
faut il faut échanger de l'émotion il
faut échanger des rapports le
télétravail l'ordinateur ne permet pas
tellement ça honnêtement
alors non mais vous avez donné leur
réponse je pense que comme vous le dire
que le télétravail a été une adaptation
la situation confinement que
probablement des gens vont découvrir que
parfois ils peuvent faire du télétravail
pour éviter un transport une partie du
travail
je fais le pari qu'une partie du travail
va se faire désormais par télétravail
mais ça sera une petite adaptation parce
que si on reste face à l'écran on
s'isole
on a des troubles comme les enfants là
des troupes de l'empathie on n'a pas des
fonctions j'ai donné des cours par mook
et en a fait l'évaluation mauvais
catastrophe après un mois après un cours
d'art moore il ne reste pratiquement
rien c'est à dire que les étudiants
avaient décroché presque tous sauf ceux
qui étaient en thèse mais on travaille
sur les ennuyer pour être pour
l'intelligence c'est pas une qualité
c'est vraiment l'intelligence une
qualité relationnelle
donc si on veut être stimulé sur le plat
intelligent il faut qu'on rencontre des
copains des copines des propres soient
d'accord autres pas d'accord qu'on
rigole quand se discute
hélas en vain produire de l'intelligence
alors il ya là un autre débat à boris
cyrulnik qui va qui va occuper toutes
les sociétés occidentales sait les
conditions dans lesquelles on est prêt à
accepter
d'abord donné
un certain nombre de libertés
individuelles pour pouvoir se protéger
du risque d'épidémie
quelle est votre position notamment sur
le tracking
alors je pense qu'on est tous en liberté
surveillée
c'est à dire que le mot liberté est un
piège de la pensée surtout à parcé
occidental surtout depuis la révolution
française
ce mot n'avait pas de sens avant avant
avance injuste de la coiffe la couronne
1794 on employait pas le mot bonheur on
employait le mot liberté syntaxe ans on
était sur terre dans une vallée de
larmes entre deux paradis le paradis
perdu
arosa temps air et le paradis a regagné
si on obéit c'est bien aux prêtres et
aux seigneurs dont le mot liberté
n'avait pas de sens et il est devenu une
valeur énorme de notre culture mais il
est impossible à définir en avril a
presque pas de liberté on a un degré de
liberté
c'est à dire que nous êtres humains on
peut inventer le milieu qui nous façonne
c'est ça notre degré lille rp mais on
n'a pas la liberté de vivre sous l'eau
on n'a pas la liberté de vivre sans
manger
on n'a pas la liberté de ne pas
respecter rythme biologique si l'on
tombe rapidement malades
donc on a très peu de liberté c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que ce devrait liberté est
encore plus précieux donc je crois que
il faut pas surestimer la liberté on a
la paix beaucoup il faut bien la
préserver mais vous vous dites et vous
l'avez expliqué tout à l'heure que le
virus ou les effets du virus peuvent
faire le lit du populisme peuvent faire
le lit d'une dictature mais on a dit
aussi que la chine régime autoritaire
avait su mieux gérer les confinements et
la lutte contre l'idée que les
démocraties
mais oui alors ça voilà ça c'est un
raisonnement logique et dangereux c'est
d'ailleurs c'est un raisonnement logique
parce que pour qu'un grand pays comme la
chine mène un grand pays comme la france
sûrement il aurait fallu qu'on soit uni
on l'a été pour le confinement
ça m'étonnerait qu'on le reste pour le
des continents
mais pour continuer le pays a été uni
l'explication des scientifiques et des
politiciens étaient claires et les gens
ont en grande immense majorité jouets
jeux et reporté une victoire relative
puisque a bien contrôlé on à diminuer la
puissance mortelle du virus mais alors
après maintenant il va y avoir un ko ko
économique chaos philosophique la mort
la liberté 20 toutes les questions
auxquelles vous m'avez invité donc ça va
ça va être le débat des des semaines à
venir
et là les gens seront angoissés par le
chaos et le danger du chaos le chaos et
déterministe vasser prigogine qui a dit
ça c'est à dire que quand il ya le cas
au nouveau déterminisme appareil est là
le danger c'est que apparaît un sauveur
vous êtes dans le cas où vous savez pas
où aller
mais moi je sais je suis prêt à mourir
pour vous votez pour moi je sais où est
la vérité
mais quand les gens sont malheureux
anxieux bousculer ils votent pour un
dictateur qui est démocratiquement élu
vous voyez qui changeront pensait
absolument absolument absolument
absolument
hitler est pratiquement élus et sur la
planète aujourd'hui d'un très grand
nombre de dictateurs ont été
démocratiquement élu parce que leur pays
savaient plus où aller et que les gens
étaient désorientés par la liberté à
boris terral dit que je n'oublie pas que
vous êtes vous êtes vous avez étudié
aussi et vous êtes intéressé aux enfants
aux petits enfants vous avez été
président des assises de l'école
maternelle c'était ans en 2018
comment est ce que les enfants peuvent
sortir d'une crise comme celle-ci est-ce
qu'ils ont un sentiment particulier ce
qui la ressentent ne pas sont précises
ou pas ils vont le ressentir intensément
mais leur réaction dépendra des
réactions des parents mélodies et des
discours sociaux si un bébé depuis la
grossesse jusqu'à la parole dans les
1000 premiers jours
son état des ports de l'état de sa mère
si sa mère est sécurisé par son mari par
sa famille dans la société même si un
virus même si un confinement énorme
le bébé neurones n'aura rien il va se
développer normalement parce qu'il aura
autour de lui tous sites dont il a
besoin pour bien se développer mais dès
qu'ils arrivent à la parole
les déterminants change je parlais de
chaos déterministe là il faudra qu'il va
bien voir quelque chose est bizarre on
peut pas sortir que ses parents sont
anxieux donc à ce moment là il faudra
parler lui expliquer si on se tait le
but de l'enfant à être anxieux il à dire
si on nous cache des choses donc un
meurtre quelques thors je sais pas où
mais j'ai peur est là il va devenir
anxieux
si on parle tout le temps on va
l'angoissé dans ce cas je cite toujours
l'exemple
après les attentats de septembre 2001
les twin towers à new york un ami a fait
des études sur le syndrome
psychotraumatiques des enfants à
bordeaux y avait il y avait certes un
chef-d'oeuvre de terrorisme et les
journalistes ont médiatisé
tel ce chef-d'oeuvre de terrorisme avec
des images spectaculaires incroyable
s'est passé en boucle en boucle pendant
des mois des mois eh bien il ya eu
énormément de syndrome
psychotraumatiques chez les enfants
bordelais alors que le danger
il était à new york mais ils vivaient
dans une représentation très angoissante
pour eux donc entre les deux mais la
seule bonne solution que c'est de dire
aux enfants d'un will en effet tu as
senti tu as compris quelque chose bien
danger mais on sait ce qu'il faut faire
pour le contrôler et on va jouer on va
t'apprendre à jouer à la guerre jouer à
lutter contre le virus et les enfants à
ce moment là vont apprendre à se
protéger sans angoisse
donc ça dépend beaucoup de la réaction
des parents et des récits culturel où
les psychologues les philosophes et les
journalistes ont un rôle majeur à jouer
sans faire de polémique vous était
partisan du retour à l'école le plus
vite possible pour les pour les petits
les petits enfants notamment
oui j'étais partisan sachant que ce
serait mauvais c'est à dire que
mais oui parce que si on le garde les
enfants confinés trop longtemps il y
aura plus d'effets secondaires que
l'effet protecteur
donc il fallait qu'il est cédée quant
aux médicaments donne plus d'effets
secondaires peuvent d'effets bénéfiques
et brandon poehl médicaments donc le
médicament confinement un marché mais si
on prolonge
il va y avoir des troubles dans les
familles il va y avoir des troubles
anxieux il faut pas arrêter mais comme
les parents sont donc légitimement
inquiet le retour à la vie publique va
se faire progressivement
il ya un tiers des enfants qui vont
aller dans les classes on va leur
apprendre les gestes barrières ils vont
jouer avec ça très bien ils vont pas
respecter les gestes barrières et ça
c'est rien ça va faire un retour
progressif à la vie donc je pense que
cette maladresse est parfaitement
adaptée ou de confinement
non mais c'est le nez je pourrais passer
des heures à vous interroger puis
surtout à vous écouter comme ça
malheureusement on n'a pas ce temps je
voudrais signaler un livre que vous
aviez publié en 2004 ça remonte déjà à
ses lois parce qu'il m'avait beaucoup
touché
parler d'amour au bord du gouffre
c'était si odile jacob déjà si vous vous
en souvenez certainement de ce livre il
raconte une grande blessure ben on peut
sortir plus fort vous trouvez qu'on
parle assez d'amour actuellement ou pas
c'est le mot clé moi j'en prends pas le
mot amour un peu le mot attachement
c'est le mot le tranquillisants naturel
ce qui nous motive faire des efforts
c'est l'attachement des restaurants vie
avec quelqu'un
une famille une femme des enfants des
copains des amis ou des coûts des
voisins dès l'instant où on vit avec eux
dans une relation d'attachement
on n'a pas besoin de tranquillisants
chimiques on a tout ce qu'il faut autour
de nous mais c'est écédemment qui
implique la socialisation et la parole
être avec partage des projets
si on arrive à mettre ça au point je
suis convaincu qu'il y aura pas beaucoup
ça drôle sinon traumatique mais j'ai eu
une petite inquiétude
boris cyrulnik merci beaucoup alors je
rappelle qu'on va retrouver cette
émission sur l'antenne rt france en
rediffusion en replay aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux sur internet
arte france point tv merci beaucoup
monsieur réunica très bientôt puis
protégeons nous c'est moi qui vous
remercie proto journée où mes rencontres
en ont vite
[Musique]